All right. So it's great that we can visualize the
winning percentage of the Red Sox from 1960 to 2010.
But what if we wanted to do a slightly more
complex analysis to try to understand what is driving that
winning percentage. We'd have to incorporate more variables. But how?
One way is that we can use the visual cues
that we're familiar with to encode even more information into
the chart. For example, let's go back to our scatter chart.
We can use the size of the points to represent the number
of home runs hit by the Red Sox players that year. Dots
that are larger meant that more home runs were hit that year
whereas smaller dots mean that fewer home runs were hit. Hopefully, what
we would see is that bigger dots occur when the winning percentage
is higher. I've filled the plot in with some dummy data just
so that you have an idea of what this might look like.
We can even double up on visual cues. For example maybe we
also use the saturation of the red color to indicate
how many home runs are hit. So our larger dots
will be a more intense shade of red, whereas our
smaller dots will be a less intense maybe almost pink shade
of red. A redundant visual cue can help reinforce what
might be a challenge to see if we only used one
visual cue. So by using both size and color here,
hopefully we really hammer home to the viewer that there were
more or fewer home runs in a given year.